♪
>> Tucker: EATING MEAT IS
PRETTY TASTY.
NOT SURPRISED MOST PEOPLE DO
IT YOU PROBABLY DO.
ARE THEY MAKING A MISTAKE
PROFESSOR OF UNIVERSITY.
SITTING NEXT TO ME ON THE
SET INTERESTING PETE'S
EATING MEAT ENTRENCHES
HEGEMONIC MASCULINITY AND
THAT FOR WOMEN GOING
VEGETARIAN PUSHES BACK
AGAINST THE PATRIOTIC AND
MAY ELIMINATE THE GENDER
BINARY ITSELF.
THE PROFESSOR JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THANK YOU.
SO YOU WROTE THIS IN THE
MY ISSUE DID NOT COME SO I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
>> I CAN SEND YOU A COPY.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T WAIT.
YOU SAY THAT VEGETARIANISM
HELPS WOMEN PUSH BACK
AGAINST THE PATRIOTIC AND
MAKES MEN MORE RESPECTFUL.
HOW DOES THAT WORK.
>> THAT'S NOT A DIRECT QUOTE
BUT VERY WELL SUMMARIZED.
YOU MUST HAVE GOOD PEOPLE
WORKING FOR YOU.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
HOW DO YOU CONNECT EATING
MEAT CARNIVORE BEHAVIOR.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF
OCTAVIA BUTLER?
DO YOU LIKE SCIENCE FICTION?
>> I HAVE A BOOK CALLED
OCTAVIA BUTLER LILUS BROAD.
>> Tucker: THAT'S LIKE A
DISTAUPIAN FEMINIST NOVEL.
>> NO, NO.
YOU GOT TO READ IT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S ABOUT
CARNIVORES?
>> YOU GOT TO READ IT TO
FIND OUT.
DEFEAT THE PATRIARCHY.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO READ IT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS THE ONE I'M
READING AND FOR ANOTHER
PARTIAL RESPONSE CHECK OUT
THIS ONE.
>> Tucker: GOOD.
SO WE HAVE SOLD A COUPLE
FEMINIST BOOKS HERE ON THE
FEMINIST.
I EAT MEAT HOW AM I
PERPETUATING THE PATRIARCHY
BY DOING SO.
>> SEVERAL WAYS.
WE TAKE UP A LITTLE BIT TOO
MUCH SPACE.
AND EATING MEAT IS A DIET
THAT REQUIRES MORE SPACE ON
THE PLANET.
OKAY?
IT REQUIRES MORE RESOURCES
TO PRODUCE PLANT BASED FOOD.
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTANDING
THAT I KNOW THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ARGUMENT
AGAINST EATING MEAT.
YOU SEEM TO SUGGEST IN YOUR
PIECE THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING ABOUT MEAT
SPECIFICALLY THAT MAKES MEN
DANGEROUSLY MASCULINE AND
THAT MEN WHO REFRAIN FROM
>> MY PIECE.
YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T READ IT
YET.
>> Tucker: I HAVE THE
SUMMARY RIGHT HERE.
>> YOU DIDN'T READ MY WORDS.
>> Tucker: I THINK THEY HAVE
QUOTATION MARKS AROUND IT?
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: DO YOU BELIEVE
MEETING MEAT MAKES MEN MORE
MASCULINE.
>> WHY ARE YOU -- I GUESS
I'M CONCERNED WHY YOU ARE
WORRIED ABOUT MEN BECOMING
LESS MASCULINE.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU REALLY A
PROFESSOR BECAUSE I FEEL
LIKE IT MIGHT BE PERFORMANCE
ART.
>> NO, NO.
I'M A PROFESSOR.
I BELIEVE WHEN YOU COME
TOGETHER, TWO INDIVIDUALS
COME TOGETHER YOU CO-PRODUCE
DIDN'T FINISH COLLEGE?
>> Tucker: YOU CO-PRODUCE
KNOWLEDGE.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: YOU TELL ME THIS.
IF I STOPPED EATING MEAT,
HOW WHY BE BETTER?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
BETTER OR WORSE.
RIGHT?
I THINK IT'S A QUESTION OF
HOW MUCH SPACE ARE WE AS
INDIVIDUALS TAKING UP?
HOW MUCH SMAS ARE WE TAKING
UP HOW MUCH WE CONSUME.
THE TEA WE DRINK.
WILL GIVE IT TO YOU LATER.
OUR BODY AND WHAT WE PUT IN
OUR HOUSEHOLDS.
HOW MUCH SPACE WE TAKE UM.
>> Tucker: YOU PROMISE YOU
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE A
REAL PROFESSOR?
>> Tucker: TOO DEEP.
I WILL ASK YOU ONE LAST
FINAL QUESTION WHICH IS I'M
GETTING THE SENSE FROM WHAT
I HAVE READ, WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WROTE IT IS ANOTHER
QUESTION BUT I THINK THAT
YOU DID, THAT WHEN MEN STOP
EATING MEAT THEY CHANGE IN
WAYS THAT YOU THINK ARE
GOOD?
IS THAT TRUE?
>> I THINK IT'S HELPFUL THAT
ALL PEOPLE CONSIDER HOW MUCH
MEAT THEY CHOOSE TO PUT IN
ANYTHING, RIGHT?
WE ALL MAKE OUR INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL CHOICES.
OUR INDIVIDUAL CHOICE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT, RIGHT?
ADAM SMITH.
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: I COME AWAY WITH
TWO STRONG IMPRESSIONS FROM
>> REALLY.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.